today's episode is brought to you by
magic mind
and if you ever wanted to really get the
most out of your mind then this will
help you do it
this is something that really just puts
you right into that flow state
instead of just shifting gears all day
quit living manually
do it automatic magic mind
dot co it's basically the organic
version of five hour energy but it's not
trash like that stuff
is it's positive stuff you can check it
out magicmind.co
use promo code theo for 10 off today's
guest is a mixed martial artist
he's a three-time bellator lightweight
world champion he's a
fitness and training entrepreneur as
well i think it's safe to say
and uh he just signed his contract for
the ufc
entering an insane lightweight division
uh happy to have him here today mr
michael chandler i'll sit
and tell you my stories
[Applause]
and what are you taking right now this
is just obviously this is just my
vitamins i freaking completely forgot
all the way
okay because a lot of rumors about you
out there what are you taking right now
i just want to know exactly
it was uh um
fish oil is fish oil turmeric
beta-alanine magnesium
bcaas and you take that once a day
um twice a day there's the formula in
the in
at night there's like one or two other
things that help me sleep i think that's
about it
okay and how i'll send you my supplement
list actually will you i do i just did
it for
my buddy yesterday i needed a little bit
of rest i don't know if i could take
your supplement
no it's dude it's all just it's all just
like the little micronutrients that
you're
probably not getting from your food
that's it and then for me for you for
all of us like just
anti-inflammatory antioxidants like
that's the most important thing
did you see a blood specialist or how
did you how do you start to get on this
regimen
i did i did a couple years ago just to
just to look at all my
stuff like where i was at hormone levels
and all that kind of stuff
um because that's the idea like how do
you how do you legally
keep your body in tip-top shape good
diet and
rest are like the two most important
thing but then it's supplementation
making sure you're taking care of your
body every
after every single workout like bcaa's
protein those are the two things that i
would
die on a diet on a freaking mountain for
those are the two things that
i've been taking over the last 10 years
that are just that have always
kept me feeling good so you take them
right post-workout obviously
protein and then you do the bcaas yeah
bc i mean pretty much i have a blender
bottle with me
three times a day like in the morning i
get up and i oh creatine so i'd do
creatine for the brain yeah the brain
who's creating when i would bust boy
actually when i bust tables well that's
the thing like
i kind of steered away from it because i
thought i thought creatine was just
like you know the freaking dudes who
just wanted the big biceps and they
freaking lift weights
in high school you know explode it was
no explode and freaking creatine
that's all it was back in the day we
didn't even read the whole label we just
thought it said knock something nobody
knew what the heck it was like it was
just like
some dumb kids out there before his test
getting two hits of it
bro you just gotta be an awake idiot i'm
pretty sure i got an a man that's pretty
good i got a good name for sure i got an
a
oh you gotta you got a d kevin kevin
always got sorry
kevin you got a d minus man kevin always
got a d
kevin was that kid who would sit in
class and he would have the hoodie and
he would close it completely
and then sit there the entire class
exactly just draw both strings down and
just have it completely shut
i'm cool miss davis leave me alone man
had a rough night um so what else you
say your regimen is sleep what is it
because when i watch you man like you
know when i watch your fights
it's like jesus christ even as a viewer
i'm like will this guy stop for a second
so
i can like it's too many frames per
minute it's like
how can i visually catch up to what's
going on here
dude it's i mean that that to me is just
that's god's just god's gifts man like
some some because you know what it is
it's i'm not afraid to freaking lose
and i'm not afraid i'm not afraid to
not like it becomes cliche i'm not
really not afraid to die in there
and i'm really not afraid to get tired
either
trust me i've been tired i've passed out
i passed out
tired yeah i passed out inside of a
fight once
from just exhaustion woke up before the
fifth round
coach carried me to the stool woke up on
the stool and then fought the fifth
round
so once you've been there you're just
like well there's really nothing that's
gonna
stop me you know and and i think it's
just it's wrestling like in wrestling
it was seven hard minutes in their face
push him out of bounds take him down do
whatever you got to do like
to win the match like shoot more times
than he does
go harder than he does foot on the gas
all gas
no brakes like didn't just go so i think
that wrestling mindset is just like now
it doesn't work as well in fighting
because it's 15 minutes it's 25 minutes
you got to be a little more you got to
negotiate those spaces a little bit more
and not go so hard all the time or else
you will die you know yeah
do you is it a psychological thing for
you in that first round because you mean
you come out in some first rounds like
dude i would even you know if they let
me wear a ton of padding i might go
against you in like a ninth round but
a first round would be somebody wanting
to die it seems like
yeah do you come out there with a
different psychology in the first round
kind of like
is that part of your mindset like i'm
put everything is right here
yeah because i think some people some
people are slow starters
and case in point like i think khabib
habib finished justin geichi the way
that he did because i think
justin gaichi wasn't ready for habib to
come out
with him come out the way they did come
out that hot so you can usually just you
can get guys
flustered you get get guys nervous get
guys scared they immediately become
a defensive fighter right away and
that's why the only fights i've lost are
the ones that
people have ran away from me you know
and i lose a split decision you know
like that's literally the only
pretty much the way that i've lost you
know when you were watching the khabib
and gateshead what were you uh
would you think after that first round
because i felt like gaechi got a lot of
time on his feet against him
a lot of it got a lot of guys don't get
that it seems like do not get as much
time against khabib on their feet
yeah no and i think i think that's that
i think that was the most surprising
thing is
is we thought the striking was going to
lean
towards gaichi's favor yet khabib i
think
the manner which could be fights is just
hectic crazy
fast pace it's not that skilled if you
go back and watch the fight there really
wasn't a ton of
strikes that were landed they landed on
justin's hands they landed on
justin's elbows forearms like it wasn't
like he hurt
uh gaichi numerous times he just got i
think he just got gait she's scared and
i hate
using the word scary because i don't
like to talk about the guys in my
division
right obviously just like not a guy who
gets scared but i know what you're
saying that that ner that energy in the
beginning or it's even like uh who was i
just talking to
oh uh well i was talking to brendan
about it i think like
it it's almost like if you get thrown
into a scenario where you're not you're
just not
ready you can make bad decisions you
know and i think justin gaichi also just
was making bad decisions on the ground
so i don't think necessarily i think
justin gaichi is that bad on the ground
i think he just got there and he was
just like
what do i do this guy's nuts you know
this guy's a freaking mauler
yeah he's like a rare snake kind of yeah
exactly they're like why haven't
scientists
found this dude yet you know it's kind
of like it's almost like you would see
him more on one of those like david
attenborough kind of like yeah
you know the david the russian anaconda
then you would like it seems like he
hasn't been discovered it's like will
somebody test
this dude yeah he's like never
reptilianism yeah or like or like
three thousand miles below the sea level
yeah yeah
bottom of the ocean somewhere he's
running on some old water
when you're watching that fight did you
think um at
all and i'm a novice fight watcher you
know i'm new into like just even
absorbing a lot of what you guys world
is like and it's
and the biggest reason is just because
it's something that so scared me my
whole life like
any like physical altercation like never
learned how to defend myself never
learned any of that growing up nobody
even
in my ear like hey just at least stand
there and get hit you know none of that
so
i definitely come from a place of
fascination did you
think when you were watching the uh
khabib and get you that that khabib kind
of let the first round happen do you
feel like he could have finished it
earlier or do you feel like um
it just that the way it played out was
the way it played out i think the way it
played out was the way it played out
because i think i mean i think
habib just was going and going and just
turned it into a fight real quick
fast paces it and i loved it i he just
fought with reckless abandon and this is
a guy who's undefeated
most of the time you see guys who are
undefeated protect that record
by fighting a little bit more uh
you know a little bit more timid or a
little bit more diplomatic a little bit
smarter you know if you will but he just
went he went in there and wanted to get
into a fist fight with with
you know the craziest striker in the
division it kind of goes back a little
bit to what you were just saying about
uh the f not being afraid to be
exhausted you know not being
because i've never thought about it like
that like i go into any sort of physical
if i'm at the gym or if i'm training or
something like
yeah i'm thinking okay in a little bit
i'm going to be exhausted out that fear
is a real
like a living fear that's in me i think
i think that's one of the greatest fears
of
of anybody across all walks of life when
it comes to
athletics like nobody likes to get tired
you know people are afraid of getting
hurt people are afraid of
of losing but man getting tired is the
worst thing in the world
now also getting tired on the football
field means you got caught you know
means you're running down you got 80
yards and you're running
and you get caught by the the d back
who's just faster than you because you
slowed down
that's not that big of a deal but you
get you get tired and locked into a cage
with another man with four ounce gloves
like
that's a scary spot to be in because
when when
when the lactic acid builds up and the
heart rate is through the roof and you
can't feel your arms and legs
and then you got a man coming at you
trying to knock your head off
that's a scary place to be and that's a
place where nobody wants to be
so you know that you know that scenario
is always right there it's only a couple
a couple crazy moves away or a couple
scrambles or
getting hurt and get your heart rate up
like it's always there
so you just have to it's like the movie
300 where he always talks about fear is
always a constant when he's when he's
talking to
his young son at the very beginning of
the movie fear is always a constant but
accepting it
that's where we win the battle accepting
the fact that you're always going to the
fear is always going to be there
and then push him through it that's
where the rub is that's where the
champions go
yeah it's interesting yeah because i
just accepted it in the beginning i was
like oh i'm just afraid as [ __ ] when i
was young
and i just never unaccepted it you know
i just never
but yeah that's interesting man i was
watching that fight last night with you
and eddie alvarez man
what a fight can you go back and watch
that sort of thing like
because i notice at the end it's almost
like a
you know you were winning the fight i
think it was four rounds to maybe you
know
i mean maybe four three one or something
in the in the final round and
um but it's still been such an amazing
battle like in that last couple of
minutes are you
is do you start to get into a defensive
mindset like okay
i have this i probably have this win in
the bag like when do you kind of
apply like strategic breaks you know
what i'm saying like yeah
like you know uh d um
d accelerate but knowing that you
already probably have the win if you can
get to the finish line
i never do and and that's not a smart
thing to do you know if you're a young
fighter listing this right now like
it's it's made me a great living it's
got me a lot of fans
because i just i'm all gas no brakes but
it's also bit me in the behind numerous
times you know and and even
you know as we talk about like i passed
out at the end of the fourth round of
the my first benson henderson fight
and then lost the fifth round i won the
first four lost the fifth round
um oh yeah right huh just because i just
kept going and it wasn't because i lost
the fifth round because i took my foot
off
the gas i just i fought so hard the
first four rounds and i didn't have
anything left in the tank and i freaking
peed blood afterwards and had
rhabdomyolysis and all kinds of crazy
stuff and
um what do you do though so when you're
heading into that type of a round like
when you're heading into that type of
that was you end up in those rounds man
you end up in those
i mean yeah the first fight against
benson that round that
uh that fight was insane i mean you you
know he took a lot of hits in that
in that whole fight i mean that thing
was crazy yeah the suplex i'm like what
i don't even know we had like roman
times like i didn't know what was going
on right
it was intense right yeah but yeah when
you're going into that type of a round
uh what do you do man so that was you
know that you've run out of a lot of
your natural gas yeah that was uncharted
territory you know i
i never would have thought i would lose
consciousness inside the fight thank god
it happened right at the end of the
bell ring and i'm just sitting there on
my knees and i'm not thinking about
anything because
you got to kind of stumbled right and
they're like that's what the announcer
said i'm not even conscious man like i
was and then i sat down
on the on the the stool one
one coaches in front of me and then this
coach behind me yells something
and that's when i like did this and then
i asked my coach in front of me did i
get did i just get knocked out did i get
choked out he's like no man this is my
my dutch
kickboxing coach henry hoofty's no man
what are you talking about man we're
going to the fifth round man you're
doing good you're gonna win this fight
yeah you're in spelling class
yeah for sure and i can i remember i
couldn't i couldn't lift my arm because
i don't think the blood
quite got to my because remember i was
you said i was stumbling because my feet
weren't working
and my arms weren't working so i
couldn't lift my hands up to protect
myself for that fifth round but
that's just uncharted territory but it's
also that that primal
animal instinct that you just have
inside you where it's like
at that point you're a you're a possum
backed up into a corner
and no matter what you just gotta fight
you either just curl your table curl
curl your tail between your legs and die
but how you how do you
adjust your strategy at that point well
at that point the strategy was the
strategy was
somewhat survive you know and and and
that's why
that's why i would say if i had more in
the tank i would have
just went forward with reckless abandon
but at some point you're like okay well
i need to take a little bit of step back
try to breathe a little bit you know
because i gotten to the point of no
return
there's a difference between being
afraid to get to the point of no return
so all the way leading up to it you
you're only fighting at 50
60 70 but if you fight at 100 get to the
point of no return after that
you're 100 is like 40
50 and you're fighting at 50 not being
uh you know offensive or or
or kind of trying to come forward but
essentially you're just you're in
survival mode and then once you get your
your wits back about your a little bit
of gas a little bit of
blood back to your brain then you can
start throwing offense again which is
that's kind of what i did in that round
even though
i essentially just got into a grappling
match with them and you know lost the
fifth round pretty bad got a big old cut
you know but uh let's go we got a
question right here riley can you hear
everybody okay
yeah you can everything's good okay
great
hello hello uh chase maldon out of
virginia
uh for mr chandler if you saw that
anderson silva fight this weekend
what are your thoughts on it and do you
think he should retire because i think
most of us do what do you think about
just you know guys kind of out of their
prime trying to fight anyway
good question good question dude a lot
of good questions came in for you man
um you know anderson silva is you know
one of the greatest of all time but when
you watch his last couple fights
it's hard to remember the anderson silva
the greatest of all time i think that's
why i think
what gsp did so well is he was like i'm
done you know i'm
i did my thing crushed it i made my
money i got a
i left a good taste in people's mouths
of a who i am as a man as a competitor
what i accomplished and then i want to
be be out the barry sanders
if you will you know um it's always good
to retire before people think you should
because the fans always want more out of
you you know selfishly the fans all of
his fans in brazil
they want more out of anderson silva
keep going keep going keep going but
before you know it you know you lose you
know in devastating fashion
again or you lose that bad again and
then people can kind of forget so i
would like to see him hang it up
even though you know it sounds like he's
going to but i
i i would have said this two three
fights ago as well man you
he's he's a he's a icon in brazil
you know he's a worldwide you know
superstar when it comes to mixed martial
arts he's
i never want to talk about someone's
money or what is enough money or what is
enough legacy or whatever but i feel
like he should have enough legacy should
have enough money should have enough
happiness should have enough
of what he's built to be able to sail
off into the sunset so then what do you
think it is that brings someone back at
that moment like what is it
like if you had to get inside of of his
mindset knowing what it's like to be a
fighter
yeah well and i think that's the
difference and i don't want to bring
other people up but i think there's
definitely been guys that you
you're like okay that guy's only
fighting because he blew a bunch of
money he needs some money
right he needs to come he needs to make
a paycheck oh if i was in brazil dude
with the drugs and women i'd have blown
it all dude
back into the ring on one foot dude well
that well that's that's the thing but i
don't think
i i right you're not saying that about
him no i think anderson silva is the guy
who just
i bet he's i bet he's set for life i
could be wrong you know like i said i
don't know the guy
personally but there's a lot of guys who
you say that guy right there
i know why he's stepping on the cage
tonight he needs another paycheck he
needs to
like nick diaz you mean well yeah i just
made that up all day
you know i mean i don't know i wonder i
don't know how those diaz brothers are
doing i bet they're doing
all right but i mean i know nate nate
diaz did all right when that that connor
fight made a couple million but
you know it's uh it's it's tough because
i'm going to get to that point
eventually you know where people are
like hey it's time to hang it up you
know
but i'm in my mind in my camp with my
coaches it's something you always have
to go back to
your family and your coaches because
you're never going to want to quit
you know you're never going to want to
stop unless right yeah that's what i'm
getting at you're never going to want to
quit no even though like a guy like gsp
i mean there's there's him on the rec on
record saying he hated fighting like he
he hated he would show up to the arena
and pray to god that the
that the comet would come down and hit
the arena and just end his misery
that freaking that someone would pull
the fire alarm that there would be a
bomb threat that there would be
something where he would just be like
thank god i could go home and don't have
to do this you know he he
talked about in and documented kind of
like the anxiety that the guy went
through
and this is one of the greatest of all
time a guy who looked unbeatable at
times you know
still does still yeah i mean still he i
think he could come into the cage right
now
at 155 170 and win the freaking title
185 possibly you know so
you never know what's motivating a guy
but you got to go back to your coaches
you know your
your closest of kin your mentors your
family and and then the people around
you that
that know no matter how much how much
more that you accomplish how much more
money you make they don't benefit from
it they just want to see
you happy you know those are the people
that's those that's those are people you
got to listen to you know
it's interesting because even in every
in every form of
entertainment or survival uh anything i
guess maybe i mean i can relate it a
little bit in my own life but
yeah you there's these voices that push
you to succeed and like
even these invisible voices of people
that naysayers you know haters that say
you can't you know
um but then at a certain point
those voices aren't really helping you
anymore it's more the voices that
actually can see you as a human
yeah and saying like okay you know we
care about you
there's no you've proven yourself
you know what do you do now how do you
manage that because there's
there's a there's a lot of mismanagement
mismanagement at that point as well
and sometimes you're so blind you just
come up so blindly like
just throwing fists especially in you
guys's career you know and i see it with
porya in a lot of his fights and his old
fights you could see
he didn't even have a look in his eyes
he's just like a you know an animal you
have that animal instinct
but then you get to a point where you're
standing on top of the cage
and you're like okay i'm not i'm not in
this i'm not fighting for nothing
anymore like
i'm at a point where i can make some
choices for myself well yeah i mean a
lot of it comes with maturity and stuff
too and
and i told you it was cool like right
around the time that we met
you know i was getting ready to go fight
and that was the first time i ever met
pourier because pourier was
cornering a guy who was on the same card
and i just went straight in connecticut
he was in connecticut
uh something yeah he just he got a
couple wins in a row yeah he's he's good
emporia was there the whole fight week
cornering him and whatnot and i just
went straight up to him because i i knew
at this point i was probably gonna go i
was probably going to
leave bellator uh and i was probably
gonna hopefully sign with the ufc
my goal was i wanted to sign with ufc so
i knew i was
about to walk up to a guy that was
probably gonna i'm gonna be in the same
division for sure i'm probably gonna end
up fighting them
but to me the respect level for a guy
like poirier or even anybody in the
division i don't
i respect you if you step inside the
cage you make your living doing what i
do doing what we do because
this is what was it i understand the
perils the trials the tribulations of
this this tough
sport that we call our our profession
but went up to him and we
were talking a little bit and i just you
know i congratulated on on his last win
he had just beaten dan hooker a couple
weeks prior
congratulating him on the fight of the
year candidate that it was it was a
phenomenal fight
his heart his determination what he does
outside the cage the man that he is the
competitor
that he is the father that he is and
then also we kind of talked like
about the journey a little bit where
it's like man 30
something years old now got a wife got a
kid got it
you know doing what we're doing is much
different than back in the day i kind of
brought up about how he was some young
shaved head punk kid on that documentary
you saw that
his documentary and that was dustin
poirier from back in the day
and he was in this documentary crazy
this is an insane thing coming out of
the swamp
exactly and but it's so cool to see
where people start
and then where people end up and and
watch and watch people's maturation
throughout the journey and
and he he would probably if he was
sitting here today he would probably say
man
you know his his career i think is a
blueprint for a guy who
who started at a certain point has ended
up where he's at
he's at the top of the game top of the
division top of the toughest division in
the in the entire world about to fight
the biggest global superstar of of mixed
martial arts and conor mcgregor
he's in a phenomenal spot but you don't
just fall there by accident you'll fall
to the top of the mountain
by just by coincidence you know he had
to build and climb
and plod and and tread towards that and
a lot of it
comes with good things happen to good
people you know and it's not though
it's not that people don't do the right
things it's that people don't do the
right things for long enough and he has
put his time
in grown into a phenomenal man father
husband and yeah he's gonna be rewarded
role model so it's cool just just seeing
the maturation process of
of of us as fighters you know a decade
later
yeah it's wild and it's also it's
interesting to see because
you know growing up like a lot of kids
in my neighborhood would fight a lot of
like you know it was a lot of like
you know a lot of poor kids kind of
fight
you know it's just something to do you
don't have cable you [ __ ] throw two
[ __ ] you know
48 pounders in the ditch and let them go
at it you know what i'm saying like just
different
dude i used to invite friends over like
kind of rich friends
and then we would go on a bike ride in
the neighborhood and i knew some kids
were going to [ __ ] fight
oh my god
my buddy's like i thought we're just
going to rent movies i'm like well dude
you got to deal with [ __ ] little
thomas hoover first son you know
this dude weighs 47 pounds but he's
dude that's funny that's a true story
that's a true story bro
one of my friends still gets mad at me
about it man but yeah i used to
one of the rich friends one of the rich
friends you guys are still friends i'm
like you'll be fine
he's got a really nice freaking harrow
with pegs on it and stuff and you
get the kid the kid comes out with a
freaking busted up mongoose like hey
what's up
hey what's up tommy hoover yeah tommy
hoover comes out dude he's got that
natural shake in him bro
you know yeah just the lord's scoliosis
bro you're just missing a couple
elements you know
but yeah i used to do that [ __ ] but so
it's interesting to get to a point it
seems it seems interesting from an
outsider's perspective
to get to a point where yeah you to come
from a place of
fighting for your peace of mind or for
your comfort or to feel okay
you know like i do stand-up comedy to
feel okay i get on a stage i need
something from people you know fighters
they
there's some we're all trying to prove
something to ourselves or to others
but to come from a place of fighting
because that's such a
physical and brute thing to then get to
a place of
having some sort of peace in your life
where um
where whatever those voices are that
probably made you so angry in the first
place
that's a wild ride you guys are on yeah
and it's and it's funny too
as the sport has evolved and even even
in the very beginning of of the sport
you know the sport
started with uh you know dana white and
these guys they didn't even
start the ufc it was it was started by a
different group and then the ufc and the
fertittas
dana white bought it and turned it into
what it is today but
i'm sure there was guys who fought just
for there was no money in it either so
it wasn't like they were trying to make
a bunch of money it was really
who was the toughest who's the baddest
dude on the planet from
what uh vocation from what background
you got you got your boxer there was
a boxer wearing one boxing glove where
he could throw a jab but he could also
grapple
he had your karate guys your sumo
wrestling guys your street fighters your
whatever
back flipper some guys get in there just
do a backflip and then get their ass
kicked yeah exactly you know see
that's how it kind of started and then
and then and then it
evolved into the sport of okay we can
make a living out of this or or it's
just a really cool hobby
so you saw guys who kind of came from a
place of anger but then you see
a guy like myself i just like
hand-to-hand combat and i
and i don't i don't really like
confrontation the funny thing is i'm
very similar to you like if someone
walked in right now i wanted to fight
i'd get this weird nervous tension and
i'm like i'm not trying to fight man i'm
not
here to fight but you put me inside the
cage with you and you and you put a
check on the line and it's a competition
and i can prove myself in a co in a
contest
of hand-to-hand combat that's when the
real competitor comes out of me because
i love
the contest but i don't like the
conflict you know
um so somewhere in between there is is
where you
so some of your drive comes from the
competition aspect of it no all of it
does i think
i mean at this point i realize that
all of my all of my admirers fans or
people
who who follow me on my platforms or
wanna
wan want to say man that guy is a guy
that i want my kid to be like
they don't do it because i can kick
people's ass like they don't care about
that
they do it because they say man that guy
is a
is a symbol and a a manifestation of a
little guy from a little town who was
taught to do little things who had a
bunch of ups a couple downs never quit
pulled himself up by his bootstraps
dusted himself off every time he got
knocked down
and became a champion because of it now
isn't is in the best position of his
career
because of of his stick-to-itiveness and
has continued and drive to move forward
and yeah it's really cool that he you
know it's a bonus that he likes to bite
down on his mouthpiece and get into a
brawl inside of a a cage inside of an
octagon
but really we like him for the symbol
of what he is the metaphor for what his
his career stands for and i think that's
what
that's what i like because to me
fighting is so much
deeper than just the 15 minutes inside
the cage the 25
minutes inside the cage it's how you
live your life the honor the respect the
integrity
and the the the character that you can
build because someday i'm gonna be
retired i'm gonna look back and say man
that was a really fun ride it was
painful at times but man i
impacted a lot of people throughout it
and we had a really good time and made
some
made some some coin to be able to take
care of my family
yeah it's funny and i i hate to keep
bringing up dustin but we're dustin
poirier fans here and uh
i'm a desperate fan yeah i'm gonna fight
him someday you know it's gonna happen
oh it would be a great fight that's the
thing like it would be a great place you
don't have to hate each other right so
it's
yeah 100 it's and it seems like there's
a lot of respect especially in that
division man there's
i mean there's some uh god that's insane
that's just bumper to bumper traffic in
that division but
yeah i remember like about a year ago
there was just kind of this thing where
you got to start to see who dustin was
as a person through his fighting
yep and it was even after the khabib
loss but i
i mean he was bummed i remember talking
we talked a little bit and i
said but man you don't understand like
people are seeing you you're becoming
like a hero to people like you're
becoming
win or loot and it doesn't matter
anymore not that that this is just my
mindset i mean obviously he wants to win
every time but i'm like you're becoming
people can see who you are through your
art and that's one thing that
that's what's really amazing i think
about having the ability to be
in some sort of performance whether it's
fighting stand-up anything if you can
or anything i mean if you're just even
if you're just somebody that's going you
know
picking up garbage if you can if people
could see your heart through
through whatever you're doing man that's
pretty powerful
dude that's that's what it is because
and that's and that's why we have to be
careful as a
as a human race as a society to be
separated from one another
six foot distance wearing masks like i
don't want to turn it into a
the political thing or the or the you
know the pandemic thing or any of that
kind of stuff but it's like
i believe god created us for
relationships and not just personal
one-on-one relationships but even the
the relationship that dustin poirier's
fans have with him
by watching him via social media by
watching him
in his fights and truth be told people
would care less about him
if he was undefeated people would care
less about him if he was perfect
yeah i love the fact that he gets beaten
up
battered bruised and then and then picks
himself back himself up
gets back on the mic and says you know
what i'm not perfect i'm not
i'm not undefeated i have blemishes on
my record look at me
you know when you mess up raise your
hand and say hey this is me this is this
is my baggage this is my loss but this
is my loss to deal with
and you can and you will say things
about me and you will criticize and you
will nitpick
but trust me this is i may have lost the
the battle tonight but the war will be
won down the line and that's
and that's what is the beauty of mixed
martial arts i have five losses on my
record
but people don't care about my losses
whenever i win my next fight or even if
i lose my next fight they don't care
they just
the best fighters in the in the entire
on the entire planet right now are the
ones with multiple losses the biggest
superstores your jar
george maswa doll has like 10 11 losses
you know like
diaz yes more losses than wins conor's
got
almost five losses now you know khabib
phenomenal what he has done jon jones
phenomenal what they have done
but it's also the ups and the downs the
ebbs and the flows the
losses and the wins that that really
draw people
to these fighters yeah and the different
types of fighters yeah it's like some
people are like yeah they just want the
undefeated
but i think more people can relate to a
guy that has uh
like a you know has the ups and downs
it's like
even like anthony smith is one of my
favorites you know and it's not
i could care less if he wins or loses
it's like every time he comes out of
that tunnel
it makes me feel like damn bro
whatever's going on in my life
i can i'll it's gonna be fine you know
this guy can do if this guy can come
back
um you know i can keep it just reminds
me that i can keep going
dude and that's so cool like even even
you just saying that like i
even it gives me a different perspective
knowing you and then
and and him like i don't i don't know
him and and i
don't watch a ton of his fights either
like it's but it's just funny how
certain people gravitate towards or are
drawn to
certain fighters and i think that's
what's so beautiful about mixed martial
arts and
obviously i'm biased because i'm in it
but it's
it's so much easier to look at a guy
like anthony smith or even any any of us
fighters
compared to like say a baseball player
who
you know he chances are the only thing
the only thing you see inside of his
performance is okay can he catch the
ball
can he run the bases can he hit the ball
we we get the luxury
of being inside of a cage fighting and
there's
second to second to second in each
second that happens inside
each of those five minute rounds is up
very very high very very low somewhere
in the middle craziness going on
uncertainty
and it's it's just a beautiful sport
it's a really really beautiful sport
and man it's just really cool to be a
part of it i would argue like wrestling
is the same
same way amateur wrestling college
wrestling i love it because it's it
built me into the man that i am but
but mixed martial arts on a global
platform is just it's such a beautiful
sport because even the guy like you who
you know anthony smith
watching him and it's just like like we
said he's in there painting a
masterpiece
of the physical manifestation of the ups
the downs the
the your your greatest opportunities and
your darkest hour that you
personally feel when you watch him fight
and maybe he knows you maybe he doesn't
like obviously you're a
celebrity but like the average person
the average person who's like anthony
anthony smith is my favorite fighter who
anthony may never ever meet
but he made that person sitting on his
couch in poughkeepsie mississippi
watching the ufc paper feel something
yeah it's really freaking cool man
pretty crazy it's powerful you guys i
mean you guys this sport is unlike any
other because there's so many moments
where it's like
okay how does this how does he approach
the beginning of the fight
uh what is this what is his behavior
been like going up to the fight
um how does he uh how is he managing
himself in this beginning like in this
kind of
capoeira kind of beginning dance feeling
each other out
uh win or lose how did they then behave
you know it's like
there's so many moments for people to
show
every side of humanity it's it's almost
yeah i think
that's why i think there's so many new
fans coming to it too it's like wow it's
not just about the fighting there's
there's just so much more to it um yeah
it's like kind of what you said too like
it's almost it's almost like of course
the fight is the most entertaining part
but man think about the walk out think
about the
you know the shaking the hands and the
hugging of your your your teammates
and your coaches before you go into
battle it's literally like
roman times where they were back in the
back and they were shaking their hands
you know like you see gladiator with the
strength and honor thing before they
went out there and
like it's don't not to sound cheesy but
that's a lot
different than so many other sports this
is so much more raw and real and it's
and and and ronda rousey said it back in
the day on this this documentary it's on
netflix called the hurt business that i
was in it was pretty
really cool documentary about fighting
and she said you
whether you love it or you hate it
you're drawn to it people are drawn
to it because even if we're the most
peaceful person in the world we are
somewhat at some level drawn to
to conflict yeah or we're drawn to sport
we're drawn to competition we're drawn
to the contest and and mixed martial
arts is
all of that rolled into one and like you
said
there's so many different aspects of the
fight that are that are
outside of just the fight the build-up
and then afterwards
whether or not me and you hated say you
know we sold it on tv that we hated each
other or it was real that we hated each
other
are we gonna shake hands afterwards are
we gonna are we gonna hug afterwards are
we yeah what's the shed tears afterwards
like what's gonna happen
you knock me out do i swallow my pride
and say hi to you know say
congratulations or vice versa
or there's any one million different
scenarios that could manifest himself
and happen inside the cage and it's
it's the most unpredictable uh sport in
the world like being tied into a tornado
every single time and that's why people
love it and that's why i love it look
you want to know about money then you
got to know about this that
americans are overpaying on car
insurance by
21 billion dollars
21 billion that's a lot
but searching for a better deal to find
out how much
you are actually overpaying it can be
real trying
but not anymore thanks to
the zebra.com the zebra.com
is the nation's leading car insurance
comparison site
so you know it's there's all these other
spots you go to next thing you know
they're calling you they're harassing
you
they're sending somebody by your house
you screaming about car insurance
screaming about head-on collisions and
stuff and honking on your horn
and knocking on your sister's window at
night that's over
the zebra doesn't do that the zebra is
the only place you can compare quotes
side by side from over 100 providers and
choose the best for you
in 90 seconds or less plus they will
never sell your information to the
spammers
ever you just answer a few questions on
a simple fast form
and they find the best rates and
coverage in your state
tech crunch magazine calls it kayak for
auto insurance
how much can you save on car insurance
go today and start saving at
thezebra.com t-h-e-o
that's the zebra.com theo spelled
t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a the zebra
dot com theo you know recently i was
struggling uh getting a refi
nance because i'm trying to get a home
and i realized that i had a bad loan
and i couldn't refinance because i made
some poor payments on a previous loan
i made them 30 days late i made them 60
days late i dinged up my credit
but thankfully that's being solved by
bridge
credit solutions they're different i'll
be honest with you they backed with a
hundred percent
money back guarantee for any items that
cannot be removed
you will not find that anywhere in
credit repair industry
you reach out to bridge you tell them
what you need done they take it on
that's how it goes so it's going to help
put me in a position where i can get the
refinance that i want
you know exactly what you're paying for
at the beginning of your credit repair
no open-ended monthly fees it's written
in the contract
what work is to be done and how much
you're paying
bridge credit solutions you will need to
have
bridge report access prior to scheduling
your audit
they cannot go over your credit report
without it thankfully it costs just
one dollar this can all be found on the
website by simply clicking on the
services drop
down bar where you will see bridge
report access
get it done it's helping me it can help
you
get those dings off your credit get the
refinance get the low rate you
deserve visit bridgecreditsolutions.com
t-h-e-o they're very personable they
take communication
seriously you can always feel free to
call or text
no matter the hour day or night that's
right
visit bridgecreditsolutions.com t-h-e-o
they are helping me they really are and
they can help you
let's go to a question right here we got
a question from a beautiful young man
right here has been smoking
question for michael fricken chandler
hey man first off
congrats on the ufc contract congrats on
making it to fight island
getting to hang out there making the cut
like a professional like you always have
been
i gotta know though i i can tell you're
a guy who likes to stay in shape you're
very disciplined but
what's your cheat like say you go out
friday night or whatever
what's your cheat meal or like just
cheat activity what do you like to do
whenever you give yourself a day off to
just
unwind i gotta know gang gang
good luck buddy okay yeah you ever pull
off the side of the interstate and have
a [ __ ] five or six doritos dude
i could see you having five or six two
cool ranch doritos individual
triangles and you freaking go only two
no man like
you know the most and i love this
question because i think i am one of the
guys that people look at and they're
just like
man that dude lives it and i do but you
also have to realize that you're a human
being
and not a robot you know i'm not a
cyborg sent back in time to freaking
you know fighting a cage like okay right
then yeah
take that question no but uh you know
just a normal person so like right now
you know you're catching me in between
like i just got done making weight
what was it pretty much like 14 days ago
yeah it was exactly 14 days ago so
for the last two weeks i've gotten i've
gotten workouts in
five six workouts so like a workout on
average every other day
just to give myself a some time to heal
and b some time to
almost feel lazy almost feel
like a schlub like you know like you eat
a little bit of crap you drink some
alcoholic beverages be like i love
taking my wife out
eating some good food having some drinks
open up a bottle of wine
but i don't feel great afterwards and it
reminds me why i go into a 12-week
training camp where there's no alcohol
there's no bad food i'm eating out of
tupperware containers or
or my mega-fit meals which is a food
prep company that i that i use
and it's all just chicken lean ground
beef salmon
turkey lamb what about a lamb maybe no
not not in there but
i do i do like lamb lambs not bad lamb
my wife makes some good lamb and then i
just couple that with like
three or four vegetables broccoli
cauliflower brussels sprouts sweet
potato and that's literally all i eat
for 12 weeks straight
so you could [ __ ] in a garden and help
it out
pretty much you know like a human human
compost and so so to answer his question
i love pizza um i i like a thin crust
pizza because man too much bread gets me
i'm not a chicago deep dish type of guy
i'm actually like a st louis style thin
crust pizza guy
true food here in town have you eaten
truffles yeah i've been over there true
food
pizza divorcees in there too looking for
that next man yeah
exactly you know you can go in there
somebody ordered me i was like
hey i'm right there good looking woman
with mullet i'll take him with a side of
chardonnay
uh and so true food pizza is actually
like one of my favorite pizzas
but um and then man uh yeah so that's
what you cheated some
so also getting yourself probably to
feel a little bit like it gives you a
place to come back from and also
rewarding your body probably from what
you went through i mean that's very kind
of native american of you in a lot of
ways
is just for sure rewarding your body
knowing that it's doing things for you
it does and and
and of course we got to be careful
because the food system that we live in
the agricultural system that we live in
is not very it's not as good as our
grandparents
our green peppers now are not as good as
our grandparents green peppers
unless you get them from the right spot
you know and trying to eat good
whole organic foods and whatnot so of
course you're doing a little bit of
damage by eating the crap but you're
also
a kind of kind of rewarding your body
rewarding your mind that okay let me
take
take the let me take my foot off the gas
a little bit let me be a normal person
for a second let me let me harvest a
little body fat and let my body
thicken back up into into a kind of a
normal a normal body
and then obviously i'll shrink it back
down once fight comes but i was in
training camp essentially from march
all the way through october with my last
two fights and
and well like the fight october 24th i
didn't actually fight but i appreciate
our man there saying making 155 like a
professional that's why i did it you
know i wanted i wanted dana white
and the ufc fan base right away to see
who michael chandler is i'm going to
show up
i'm going to be there on time on weight
i've never pulled out of a fight never
said no to a fight i've never missed
weight show up on the dot
who were you most excited so say you're
there i mean you were there
and overall was it a good experience was
it pretty crazy going over there had you
ever been to the middle east i had not
been in the middle east but
to me it was just more my first fight
week with the ufc and it couldn't have
been
better man it was so awesome obviously i
think
fight island fight week is a little bit
different than other fight weeks so they
rolled out the
red carpet for us they you know i was
just getting to rub elbows with
my new colleagues my new my new
co-workers the from
dana white all the way down to the
person who like checks you in at the
very beginning who's
kind of new to the ufc all of them are
the new heartbeats that are in my life
they're it's part of my company
who i'm going to you know kind of sail
off into the rest of my career with
working with so i wanted to make it a
good impression on them show them who i
am
show them did you wear cologne or not be
honest cologne no
axe really no i'm joking no
do people wear axe anymore sorry i don't
know great if you did it'd be awesome
hey i'm just wondering i gotta go check
in
yeah totally i'm sure this is guys doing
that
yeah yeah uh but yeah i just wonder if
you put on cologne or something yeah
because you're showing up you're kind of
the new kind of kid in the candy store
you're also kind of the new candy in the
candy store i am it and it's great too
because i'm not just
i'm not the young kid who got a really
sweet spinning back kick knockout from
dana white contender siri who's
19 years old right i mean you can say
sugar shawn o'malley if you want to
oh yeah actually actually that is
exactly who he is
but he came in great but yeah no but i
like you know sean's amazing and and
but you don't have that young you don't
it's not like you have you this youthful
hype you have this long trajectory yeah
and anybody who
the good thing is and i talked about
this the other day
you you can't outrun your reputation and
your reputation
takes years to build and seconds to
break down and just
fall by the wayside you know and i i
think i think i have a good reputation
in the industry you know when it comes
to
and it was and it was great it got me in
trouble with a lot of the journalists
throughout my free agency process
because you know the biggest names in
in mixed martial arts like journalism
were like hey man give me some inside
information hey man let me break the
story but
i'm like listen back off this is gonna
i'm gonna let the ufc do their thing
whenever whenever
it comes out it's gonna come out i don't
i didn't get into the position that i'm
in without being a phenomenal employee
be a good employee and that's what these
young kids miss they got to remember man
you're still an employee these guys
still sign your paycheck don't bite the
hand that feeds you
and that was me protecting myself
protecting bellator from before i
left bellator that was me protecting the
ufc that was me protecting the other
organizations that i was negotiating
with even though i knew i was most i was
gonna
head in the ufc direction if that door
opened itself but
you know i had a good reputation coming
into this
fight week and i think i exceeded x
people's expectations i hopefully were
like hope i had a lot of
a lot of the ufc reach out to me and say
hey man this is great to work with you
you're easy to work with
you're eager i also just got done
talking yesterday to the one of the ufc
pr people and it's like
i appreciate you saying that but you
have no idea how underutilized i feel
like i've been over the last 10 years
you know
no offense to bellator but they didn't
use me enough they didn't build me
enough they didn't give me the outside
the outside uh opportunities to be on
the big stages i
i was utilized at about 20 percent i
believe
20 percent was me stepping into the cage
putting on great performances for them
which that's
you know one of the most important parts
but when it comes to being an athlete
man
microphones cameras voice word of mouth
that's how you build a great platform do
you feel like it's uh do you feel like
it was any
like like it was a shun towards you at
all or do you just feel like it's just
their company the way it is the size of
the company
you know like you can only get so big at
kmart you know before you walk into
walmart you're like damn you know they
got everything 100 no
i think it was it's their business model
they are they are the legitimate number
two organization in the world
and their business model was hey we're
gonna run a skeleton crew we're gonna
put on
the best fights we can and we're going
to we're going to coast and we're going
to do our thing
that's fine but that's not it's it was
against the antithesis
against the theos of who i am what i am
is
is moving forward taking chances
investing time energy resources to
eventually reap the benefits and i think
that's what
that's what dana white and the ufc have
done man they they
you saw it during the pandemic dana
white was the first person to get on the
microphone and say we will be back we
will be the first sport back
and you know guys like guys like i mean
it was it was uh
justin gaichy tony ferguson headlined
that that first card
and those guys were waiting in the wings
and i'm over here in bellator last fight
on my contract worldwide pandemic
waiting man when am i going to get the
fight and that's when fighting is
growing
fighting in itself like was growing at
that point like i started to learn a lot
more about bellator like
nick davis is our producer back in l.a
and he's a huge
uh degenerate gambler and mma fan and um
but he's always like he knows every
fighter from top to bottom of every
organization
but he started getting me into different
bellator he's like you got to watch this
um so it's and even then fighting was
growing and so it is interesting kind of
that maybe
were you was bellator missing some
opportunities to grab onto some of that
market share even if
ufc was the one that was kind of leading
it 100 percent
one one thousand percent because even
even though
you know they're different organizations
and and i think bellator
i think bellator it of course they used
you know they use the
coronavirus a pandemic in which the
whole world right now if if you you know
order a t-shirt offline it takes an
extra two weeks all they got to say is
well it's
coveted oh it's crazy everything it's
like you know it's like like we were
saying like you could go freaking rear
end somebody be like oh man i'm sorry
dude
you know covet and yeah it's like
coronavirus
so it's like everybody can use that and
not to downplay you know the disease but
people can use coronavirus right now as
as a totally
an excuse for anything and oh i told a
guy you get an erection i was like i got
it
coronavirus exactly homovirus in my
penis
she's like it's nervous it's about
coronavirus but i had somewhere else but
she was a nice girl too actually man
she [ __ ] took care for like two weeks
hoping it would get better and it didn't
oh my god you know maybe it wasn't green
she brought you soup yeah it might just
be erectile dysfunction yeah
um so yeah it is interesting to see how
they haven't
maybe it maybe haven't picked up a lot
of like
or just haven't grown their own business
and maybe they have i don't know but you
didn't feel like they were
no they haven't and they have grown and
they've they've built and that was the
thing about it like
i was i was content too and i said this
i i knew i was probably going to make a
change but i would have been
happy as well getting a really great
offer from bellator and
and retiring there and doing all that
and maybe maybe that was true maybe
maybe it was just a little bit of
negotiation taxes but there was part of
me that that that said man like i
i cared about those guys i cared i cared
about building that organization is not
who they are without my fights with
eddie alvarez oh man benson henderson
me losing to will brooks and then coming
who was that pigskin guy you lost what
was that guy's name
pigskin no what was his nickname punch
uh
punch dog or something pitbull pitbull
pit bump
sorry i didn't know i didn't know who it
was
exactly did you feel bad did you feel
were you bummed that you didn't get to
fight him again before you left
no and that's that's the beautiful thing
about it i i've never really i'm not
about
because to me it's not the person and
trust me i
there's no more animosity that i've ever
had with any of my
opponents than him because he's made
some baseless claims about me using peds
and just this kind of silly stuff that
has no
there's there's no he has a brother that
does it either like a stunt double or
something like a twin brother that's a
machine
for sure and they're both they're both
from brazil they if anything they you
know
probably have dab or and it's like
so i'm not really worried [ __ ] papaya
yeah
exactly so so we've had we had some you
know our
interactions where we don't really like
each other but to me i'm like i don't
need to get that one back i don't care
the funny thing is i'm in a much better
position right now getting ready to
fight i'm one i'm one degree of
separation away from fighting for
ufc title i will be ufc champion by july
of 2021
so you think i'm worried about his
little self you know
yeah disgruntled he is he's not he's not
happy about his contract he's not happy
about
his promotion or where he's at or what
he's doing he's just an unhappy person
and
he wanted to throw shade at me because
he has a scarcity mindset where
whereas i have an abundance mindset and
there's and it's very important to
distinguish the two
a scarcity mindset says because you are
having success that
that is going to take away from the
success that i could possibly grab
because there's a pie there's a pie and
there's only so much of it
man there's an abundance of of money
there's an abundance of success there's
an abundance of impact out there for you
to grab and your success
does nothing to take away from my
success that i'm allowed to have or able
to have and
there's a lot of people that's huge man
and i've struggled with that in my own
success like getting more successful and
then getting scared you know and
operating from a place of fear man
that's it's very
and and it's it's the it's the wounds of
our past the
the stories that we've told ourselves
man i've told myself so many stories
inside my head that
where i would just sabotage myself and
give myself permission to lose instead
of permission
to to win permission to be successful
you know i grew out of it after college
luckily
but i just under performed so much in
college that
i said man i got to stop this i got to
figure something out i got to take
extreme ownership of what's going on in
between these ears like you are what you
are and where you are because of what
has gone into your mind and the stories
and the in the
the myths and the trends that you tell
yourself over
you know your 30-year life or 40 your
life your 15 year old life whatever it
may be and
man you got to you got to kick that in
the teeth
here's a guy right here who has a
question right here
hey mike and theo it's aaron from
oklahoma city
well this is a question for both of you
i guess theo you already have one but
mike would you ever consider growing
a nebraska nick warmer
you got that work of that bromane maybe
hanging off it maybe that's nice and
nice and not did he straighten that he
may have straightened he also may have
dyed it a little which i don't mind
what do you call it uh nebraska that's
skunk dip i don't know what it is uh
what's that you call it the nebraska
nebraska or you play the end of that for
us again riley
yes theo you already have one but mike
would you ever consider growing
a nebraska nick warmer
neck warmer baby good have you ever
tried to uh
you know to increase your flare by doing
something wild like that you ever do a
rat tail or something i could see you
with a rat tail man i could i could do a
rat tail no
i i mean i haven't i haven't really i
mean the
i did have a haircut that was kind of a
little edgy you know when that movie the
fury came out with brad pitt i don't
know brad pitt where he's the tank war
he's not taking
that pitcher do you mind riley uh he's
the tank uh
operator and he's got like four other
guys three other guys shia labeouf and
some young guy and
michael uh michael sarah michael sarah
michael sarah the skinny little white
guy yeah no not him michael
pena the like uh the latino guy yeah
he's hilarious yeah he's awesome
greatest haircut of all time dude and
you know he's got freaking
you know he's got plugs in in the front
or something where he got a hair
hair transplant had that hairline yeah i
got it did you really
yeah i got some of the mullet taken out
of the back and put into the front bro
did it ever fall out unprecedented i
don't know i don't even know if it ever
even came in that's the problem
they they your hairline's like your
hairline's perfect though right they put
you to sleep
and then they or they don't put you to
sleep but they take it out of the back
and they put it into the front and so
the robot
uh no i have it do them hand by hand
some [ __ ] robot back there
you know what i'm saying that's how i
have a [ __ ] mustache
don't record this right now cause i are
you recording
it's fine i have a mustache because i
thought about it man like i got a
freaking
receding hairline you could do it easy
man it's real easy process
that's cool i thought about trying to
find somebody locally that would uh
do it pro bono you know just to talk
about it i mean everybody's had it done
there's there's a
pla there's we grow hair dot com oh i've
seen the way i've seen that
you see the billboards right we grow
hair that [ __ ] sounds vague it's [ __ ]
up
i'm not trying to find a sharecropper
i'm trying to find somebody see this is
important this is important for for our
you know like our like you know 30 40
aged graphic where it's like man you
know a lot of people got some got some
head like look at the one look at brad
pitt right there
in his tuxedo man like look at that
hairline that is absolutely perfect yeah
go click on that
uh riley please he's from missouri man
you know wow
but but anyway so that was probably the
most uh that was probably the most
kind of statement of a haircut i ever
made is i kind of did the fury for a
little while till my receding hairline
started creeping up too much and i was
like i mean it's
not working anymore i got to go with
this fauxhawk thing yeah it falls good
though
it's longer now i gotta get a haircut
but so yeah so that's about as
wild as you would go in the hair world
yeah i think so i'm going to ask you let
me ask you about um
and sorry if riley seems a little off
right they just had his first kiss
actually the other day
kissed a girl for the first time really
what's her name man
uh where are we maddie yeah okay you
like her well
let's just say i did you did what
something happened
oh yeah uh last night i found out yeah
that she kissed another guy oh it was
way more than that
oh gosh oh my god man i'm sorry dude i
didn't know that and
unfortunately we didn't have you on mike
today either riley i'm sorry about that
but
man well you had a first kiss
yeah a long time ago it wasn't bro who
was it be honest
uh i don't i don't remember
okay brandy
it was brandi with an eye oh yeah bro
brandi with an i
always kiss people dude brandi with an
eye yeah is the most missouri is that
where you're from missouri yeah missouri
is the most missouri
randy with an eye lifts close to the
interstate bro i know that
brandi with an eye she used to uh she
used to invite all the rich girls
into she used to invite the rich girls
over and they'd ride bikes out and
they'd get in fights with the the other
kids yeah the poor kids
my kind of girl brand new that i
my first one was chrissy with an eye
christie hello christy when i would come
out of the woodwork and beat up mongoose
like what's up girl
you're on the wrong side of the tracks
[Laughter]
christy with a high damn so riley man it
fell apart huh yeah it did
oh sorry how do you feel about it you
all right are you
i'm i'm keeping it together keeping it
together that's good i am
well thanks for being here today man i
didn't know that that had happened and
we'll discuss it next time
um and sorry you had to be here to learn
about that news as well mike yeah what
the heck man
but it's not you man it's her you know
it's definitely her it's her loss man
um here's a young fella right here he
says post malone dude
that could be post malone this one's for
mike i'm just wondering how long does it
take to get that freaking insanely
ripped
is it something that um it's always been
with you
or at one point when you started to
fight you know and do what you're doing
in training
did you notice it happening over time
and if so how long
gang gang gang brother yeah you're the
when i envision you being born that's
what i envisioned i envision you come
out of the womb
you turn around and then you start doing
the ropes exercise with your own
umbilical cord
i like that no i think that's pretty
much how it happened
no i uh who got you into fitness
i mean i just it was a it was a it was a
byproduct of what i have to do
you know and i i just truly believe and
i and i get this all the time like
people will see me squatting heavy or
bench pressing heavy or
doing some dynamic stuff and people like
oh my god i'm my knees hurt just
watching that or my back hurts just
watching this and i just
i feel for people because i don't know
what position they're in or what their
background is or how much they have or
haven't worked out but i truly believe
i've wrestled i wrestled for um
12 years or whatever and now i've been
fighting now for 11 and whatever it is
20 last 20 years i've been wrestling and
then now fighting and i have very few
injuries and i think a lot of it has to
do with
i think there's a genetic component
there's a luck component of course i'm
never gonna
never gonna act like there isn't but
lifting weights heavy
external force of adding weights and
lifting heavy and bulletproofing your
body through strength and conditioning
has really made my body
you know very very dense i think my bone
density is very very
high and i get very few injuries because
of
strength training so i just loved it and
i realized if i can
put put in the work in the weight room
it's going to bulletproof my body inside
those wrestling matches inside those
wrestling practices and now inside the
mixed martial arts world and so i've
been doing it
since college i mean college we lifted
two three days a week heavy
hard intense and then we were wrestling
six days a week so my body just became a
machine but
you know to answer his question it takes
me about 12 weeks
you know to get primed up to get
completely primed up you know to go from
you know 10 but i never get above 10
body fat
and that's one of the things about mixed
martial arts people like oh he walks
around at 198
and cuts down to 155 or 190 and cuts
down to 155 and it's like yeah
but how fat is he how how chunky is he
you know we can all
have a propensity to get chunky and get
heavy but
for me i keep i keep my weight around
180 two to 187
max usually right around 183 to 185 um
and 10 body fat you know because i just
don't like to get that
far out of shape and then it takes me 12
weeks of discipline
to shrink my body a little bit obviously
a lot of get rid of a lot of body fat or
probably six percent get down to about
four or five
six percent body fat lose a little bit
of muscle
and then get down to 155. damn dude i
freaking i think i ate 10
body fat last night honestly yeah
um when you're in uh when you're in
uh dubai right that's where the fight
abu dhabi sorry when you're in abuja
and and it's getting close to fight time
did you have an inkling are you getting
word from people there that
both guys are making the fight like are
you is there a point where it starts to
feel like okay
i might actually be a real substitute
and then it goes from okay this is i'm
just gonna be here yeah i mean i it
wasn't until the day before wayne's that
my man that my manager even kind of
asked
you know and then even then the ufc was
essentially like
well i would imagine you know by by the
morning after fight
fight or the morning after weigh-ins the
day at the morning of the fight by the
time that
we get word that habib and gaichi both
pass their coveted tests and they're
negative
you know you you should be pretty good
to go and then they were like well but
actually
like what if they get hurt on the way to
the arena it was one of those deals
where i was essentially just the backup
all the way until those guys stepped
into the cage
at that point i you know had pizza for
lunch because
i mean what was i going to do like just
continue to eat chicken and broccoli all
the way till 9 pm and no
you know at that point you kind of just
look foolish you're just hanging out
outside of the ring like
going like this yeah exactly exactly and
it's one of those things too where it's
like
it would be an even better story i i
also like of course we joked
like with my manager my manager long
time manager randall allman was there
who
um good friends with but he also handles
my stuff so we were there and it was
like
maybe just you know go like have a
celebratory beer or celebratory
you know have drink before this and be
like well yeah what if i get the call
joke and be like well kind of even
better story great story even better
story got the call while you know they
just pour to stella or something you
know and i'm eating a pizza
chandler beat khabib after two mai tai
exactly
you know like so i didn't end up having
an alcoholic beverage that day until
after the fights were over whatever but
it would have been we were just joking
like it would have been an even better
story
and who would you let's go sorry guys i
would say and in some ways it would
probably make me fight even better
because i'd be like
i got nothing to lose for sure because i
just had you know two my ties and uh
um who would you was there a rather when
you're like if you started to think like
who would i rather fight
i i my answer to that is i love
i would love the idea of fighting both
of them but at that point you have to
fight khabib just because he's the
number one guy oh wow really
yeah because if you're gonna fight i
mean yeah it would be better to have a
12-week training camp focused just on
habib obviously when you have the
opportunity of a lifetime to
you know beat an undefeated fighter the
best fighter in lightweight history
and get the world title um but for me
you got to take the opportunities when
you can they don't just hand out ufc
you know title fights like it's nothing
so um
for me it would have been habib just
because i would have had the opportunity
to capture the belt that night
uh and a fight with me and justin gaiji
is going to happen just like i said the
fight with me and poya is going to
happen these fights are going to happen
but so if you had the opportunity and i
knew we all knew habib
we didn't know he was going to retire
that night or at least say he's going to
retire we don't know yet but
i thought for sure he's going to have
one maybe two fights left in him so you
want to i want to get that fight before
he retires
i would not want to get that fight but
but that's a different mindsets man
now is when you're there and you're in
that environment is there a level of
royalty that kind of proceeds and
surrounds khabib that doesn't surround
anybody else in a way
no i yeah i'm not i'm not really i'm not
that
do you feel is there anything like that
in the air no i'm just wondering well he
wasn't there that much to be honest with
you like i saw
justin gates a couple times his mom and
dad were there his brothers his brother
looks just like him they're all from
arizona they're kind of doing their
thing
man me and justin gates are very similar
man small
town blue collar wrestling families like
that's
it looked like my family walking around
if we were in in abu dhabi
at a at a hotel somewhere so he was
there he was
present and he was seen a lot had a
couple conversations with him or his
team or whatever
habib was nowhere to be found habib had
like his own training facility he had
his own
hotel he had his own everything he
showed up in armored cars and
motorcades and helicopters and all kinds
of stuff so
he is like royalty over there because
it's middle east it's close to russia
he's he's uh
muslim you know so he's he's like
royalty so there there is but for me as
like a red white and blue blood in
america i'm like
this is silly man right now it's like
whatever you know right so
but you got to respect it now i don't i
don't want to i don't want that to come
off like i don't respect
him like i respect him a ton as a
competitor inside the cage what he's
done his accomplishments
plus winning his last fight after the
loss of his father and all that kind of
stuff i respect him respect the heck out
of him for that but
for the most part he was like that's
just like all right bro
and i don't know he showed up he looked
like a skeleton at weigh-ins he looked
like
it was it was questionable whether he
even made weight wow you know
you're just like dude be a professional
make the weight
show up with your chest puffed out a
smile on your face do your job
yeah there's a video where it says it
looks like they didn't even check his
weight kind of
did you supposedly they did you know did
you i mean
does that seem normal to you did it feel
i mean i will say i will say daniel
cormier brought this up
and it is true they at the hotel
i had to step on the scale and i weighed
154.9
and uh then they said okay you can get
on the bus
so if i was 155.2 or whatever there
they might have been like no you know
you can't get on the bus until you cut
the weight
then again maybe habib was like i'm
right at 155.1 by the time i get over
there i can float point one maybe the
scale
it's a a lot of times your balance
scales you know those old-school balance
scales are a little bit more lenient
than
your digital scale because the digital
scale will tell you point boom whatever
it is right
the balance scale all they have to do is
have a little bit of daylight
and you're technically in there so
there's almost like a 0.2 swing
yeah um but yeah i mean he stepped on
the scale it was going up
they swiped it and but it's you know
it's conspiracy theory
yeah i mean it's it's man they've been
doing this for 26 27 years
you know there hasn't been many
controversies so whatever it wasn't
meant to be for me to step inside the
cage tonight nor nor would have
if khabib didn't make weight at that
moment he would have got time to cut
weight anyway so
i wasn't worried about it um here's a
question right here from a young fellow
right here
what up theo it's your boy brody from
spartanburg south carolina
calling with a question from michael
chandler how you keep your head held
high after
ass whipping that's something i want to
know
gang baby love you love you too bro well
i know it's for michael but i i'll tell
you i remember when i was in school i've
told this story before but they
some kid beat my ass right which is easy
to do
if i was somebody else i would beat my
ass you know what i'm saying bro so
don't take a lot of
clout out of it you know like easy dude
i was it was easy to beat my ass but
uh but afterwards at school they made us
stand in the hall
me and the kid that beat my ass and hope
put our arms on each other's shoulders
and we had to stand like that all day in
the hole so then like
i ended up becoming friends with the guy
he's still a friend of mine today this
kid brad castleman great guy
no way um yeah and it wasn't that good i
let him i let him hit me a couple
first three or four times i let him hit
me and then i fell down bro that was my
so you didn't get in trouble you just
had to do that
we had to do that yeah that's cool dude
that's but it was interesting because by
the end of the day we were friends dude
you're like well we gotta say oh man
what so what do you like to do for fun
yeah yeah i'm totally proud that was it
right
like i know i hated you this morning but
like dude i really hate brad i really
hate joe you know like
yeah let's go we should go find joe man
bro come over i'll invite you over this
weekend
i got a rich kid coming over once you
come over and help me he's coming over
in his real shiny yellow horror with the
gyro over on the front
pegs yeah and his duck head freaking
shirt and shorts
um what uh that's a good question though
how do you
how do you maintain some composure and
keep your head up after a loss
man i think uh kind of like what we were
talking earlier is it's it's all about
the process
too you know if whenever you realize
that the journey
is really the process you know like the
process is the goal the journey is the
goal realizing that you're going to have
wins you're going to have losses
and i realized over the last couple
years and it took me a while to realize
this that
every single person that i've ever
looked up to whether i know them or
there's
or or there's some sports figures some
icon i'm like man that person i respect
them
they all have losses in their past
they've all have ups they all have downs
every single person you've ever looked
up to who has one has at one point or
another been a failure
failure of a competition failure or
failure of something
so when you realize like my next fight i
might lose i don't know
but don't be afraid of the loss don't be
afraid of it but when i have lost
for me it's the it's it's the beauty of
it being the most embarrassing one of
the most embarrassing moments of your
life because it's not like
you lost a a baseball game it's not like
you lost a football game and you just
lost a fight
you know you just got bested by another
individual who is getting their hand
raised while you have to hang your head
or
and and collect half a paycheck and go
home and lick your wounds
um but i think it's just once again
realizing that losses are part of the
journey
right you know lick your wounds get
around the most important people in your
life be around the people that love you
be around
the people that believe in you be around
the people that love you whether you win
or lose make sure you stay built up
and then take notes on how you can get
better how you can how you can become a
better
man competitor woman whatever it may be
wow man dude i wish you lived in my head
bro that would be helpful i could live
well we live in the same city now it's a
good point dude it's close man it's
pretty clean close pretty close because
that's definitely getting closer
uh here's a question right here that we
have from a young man
what up theo gang brother uh what up
michael hope you're doing well
hope your brain works all right uh mine
doesn't
you know nine concussions and whatnot
but i imagine you feel similar sometimes
anyways i was wanting someone who's like
just getting into fighting and stuff and
like wanting to have that ability of
of of true self defense not just
swinging and wailing
um if if all i'm doing is watching these
videos right and not going to any
classes or anything like that what would
you say is the number one thing to pay
attention to some of the takeaways that
someone who is
overall like a youtube type learner how
can what can i do to take away from from
actual
legitimate professional fights that
would help me
if i were to get in some sort you know
scrap of dapple
out here on these streets because it
gets tough out here in the central east
sometimes
amen you know so uh yeah man just
wondering what some of that advice might
be
i love what you guys do keep it up theo
you're the man
gang gang brother let's keep rolling
amen let's keep rolling man
that's a good question man because a lot
of net bangers out there they call them
when food's going wild they call them
net bangers and it's just me like
people that are learned just doing stuff
only on the net not in real time
but that's a great question man nine
concussions damn bro he's [ __ ]
thinking with a rubik's cube at that
point
that was no offense bud but um but yeah
that's a great question michael what do
you got
yeah i mean uh there's a lot of people
you've talked about there's a lot of
people learning things through youtube
these days but i mean whenever when
you're watching fights
whether it's you know hopefully it's
professional fights you know so you're
you're learning from professionals if
you will um
man defense is underrated you know keep
your hands up
uh learning watch watch how in a fight
people use the distance and the timing
a lot of times it's not necessarily the
biggest
punch that lands the one that they see
coming it's the one that they don't see
coming because you timed it perfectly
so when you watch some of these crazy
knockouts where a guy's looking looking
at you this way
expecting you to throw that jab but the
hook comes here and hits him in the in
the
in the chin from almost a side the side
you know
the t the distance the timing defense um
and then the space between the two the
spatial awareness of of the the fighters
whether they're
uh going in for a takedown and then
throwing an uppercut
or looking like they're gonna throw a
head strike
and then go for the takedown you know i
mean obviously i don't know if my man's
looking to get into mixed martial arts
fighting in professional rings or if
he's just like he said
you know in the streets i guess he was
saying in the streets just have a little
bit of uh
self-defense but can you learn from
youtube or do you have to get out there
and practice
i think fighting you need to be that's
something you need to need to be there
in the physical like in in person i
would say you know like obviously
you know you can you can't watch some
[ __ ] on your phone and then go fight i
mean it's gonna be harder
it is i mean i mean obviously there's
something to be said for fighters like
myself who uh
who i watch film and then i can like
almost learn through osmosis and say man
okay in my next sparring session i'm
gonna try this but
without that sparring session it was
just you know
and it's also real time it's fast the
craziest thing about fighting
is it's just so fast you're constantly
reaction time and you only get that
reaction time
through 10 000 hours of repetition and
getting after it so you got to be there
there in the physical form i don't know
if they're in the central east if his
if his mma gyms are open now because of
the pandemic but man
get somewhere and get some drills in you
know in america we have
sometimes traditions that you know are
half half-handed
or haphazard and old-fashioned
it's kind of wild to think that a lot of
people are still wiping their buttocks
instead of washing it after they go to
the toilet or do toil it
hello tushy cleans your butt with a
precise
stream of fresh water for just 79
i mean let's be honest with each other
for years bidets have been available
but hideously expensive costing
thousands of dollars
you see a bidet maybe uh you know jeff
bazis has one
or you know richie rich's daddy has a
bidet
but times have changed because with
hello tushy
you don't wipe at all wiping is over
even the best two-ply just can't cut it
when it comes
to a hands-free booty cleaning
experience
ditch paper products and uncomfortable
chafing when you switch to the soothing
cleansing stream of water
from a hello tushy bidet attachment
and every hello tushy bidet attachment
comes with a 60-day
risk-free guarantee and a 12-month
warranty
join millions of happy hello tushy
customers
right now and have a clean butt with
every flush that's right go to
hellotushy.com
t-h-e-o to get 10 off this is a special
offer
for our listeners clean your booty right
clean your booty right go to
hellotushy.com
theo for 10 off hello tushy dot com
slash theo so when you see
you see like the fight between dustin
and connor supposed to happen
right um is there a preference and i
watched you the other day you were
talking about like a top 10 guys and
kind of raiding the top ten just just
sharing your thoughts on them you know
i thought it was really real eloquent
about it and shared some nice thoughts
about all the guys um
um is there like a fight that you really
want is there a fight that you
does it change day to day week to week
like a month ago if i'd
asked you was it a different person than
today so a month ago if you would ask me
i would have said
you know it's tony ferguson um but then
after habib we saw my retiring and then
justin gates he was talking about
fighting within six to eight weeks
and then also connor and poirier were
talking about fighting 170 dana white
has made it very clear
if those guys are fighting 170 they're
not going to be you know
they obviously aren't going to be
getting a title shot you know anytime
soon
um as soon as habib retired you know i
was like hey man i'll fight justin
gaichi
next week for the title six weeks from
now november december [ __ ] i'll fight
him at the breakfast buffet yeah
i'll fight him next tomorrow morning
before the plane takes off you know like
let's just
keep keep the octagon set up let's go uh
you know so so that was then so at that
point you that you're like yeah
so khabib's retired they kind of changed
things it changed things and i said hey
i'll fight i'll fight dustin
or i'll fight tony or gaichi
for you know whether it's the number one
contender spot or whether it's for the
title
because you had connor and and poirier
talking about fighting 170 so they were
almost
out of the discussion still right now
you have
connor and poirier it looks like it's
almost done it looks like they're going
to be fighting 155 so those two are
booked
you got gateshea who just fought so
chances are he might want a little bit
of time off
so i think tony ferguson i say tony
ferguson for two reasons number one
he makes the most sense because he's
been the guy who set out the longest and
secondly
if i if i do think habib is coming back
i would say
he's beaten connor khabib has beaten
conor he's beaten pourier he's beating
gaichi now
and he the only fight left out there for
him was the ferguson fight but if i
beat ferguson i leap frog ferguson and
now you get chandler habib for
his 30-0 fight or 29 in one fight
instead of tony ferguson so that kind of
gives me the best option to
to win leapfrog him fight a top five guy
and be the most appealing matchup the
most challenging match up for habit or
magamadoff wow
was it disappointing um when
and have you talked to tony about it you
guys had some exchange about it right we
didn't exchange a little bit
um and then even he he commented on one
of my instagram posts like
train hard see you soon you know yeah so
he's such a unique guy he's such like a
yeah he's such a
he is an anomaly kind of he's an anomaly
he's a unique guy you don't know
you don't know you don't know what he's
going to say and then you also don't
know what he's going to do inside the
cage
you know so it's wild and it's just like
i think it's a perfect
it's a fight that scares me you know so
it's a fight that's great you know it's
great for me it's great for
great introduction for me so he's a top
five guy he's a scary guy he was 12-0
before
he was on a 12-fight win streak before
he lost his last fight we can't forget
that like he's still
one of the most dangerous guys in the
division definitely the most
unpredictable guy
and how quickly that gets forgotten
after the gaechi fight so
he's in a crate i mean how quickly
suddenly he's like he seems
like there's this uh you know yeah he's
not the same guy
exactly and granted he took a lot of
damage in that fight but still man like
we all take damage you know we all
win or lose we take damage you know uh
so it's just
it is a very much and that's the hardest
thing about it but i think it's also the
most beautiful thing about it
because the some of the fans do realize
what us fighters have to go through like
that our head is on the chopping block
essentially every single time we fight
where it's like man it's it's a what
have you done for me lately business
but going back to like you were talking
about poirier it's like it's cool to see
his
he he's become a hero win or lose he's
been one of those guys who are going to
come in if he wins people love him if he
loses people are
rooting for him wanting to pick himself
back up and get back in the wind column
and i looked at myself that kind of same
way i'm gonna
i'm gonna come into the ufc no matter
what i might have you know five fights
left in me 12 fights left to me but
either way there's a bunch of big fights
out there for me to just have a blast to
be put on this
you know awesome platform who knows i
could go 500 the next
six fights i could go 8-0 my next eight
fights i could win the title and
hold it for ten years i don't know you
know so we'll see it's wild man
it's crazy and and it's so it's amazing
really that 155 is i mean it's really
almost the bet i mean it's
is there any division that has that much
that many individual guys who have so
much
just like you're saying they can all
fight they could all stay in that in the
top 10 for the next five
10 years yeah i i don't think so not not
when it comes to divisions you know you
got your individual guys and
then you've got a guy like israel
arasana who's who fights at 185 now he's
going up the fight for the title at 205
and jon jones just left 205 went to
heavyweight and
as adasana is talking about going up to
heavyweight so that right there kind of
shows you that there's not a ton of
depth in some of these and i don't say
that like they're still
it's sometimes the depth that sometimes
it looks like there's a lack of depth
because
the champion has beaten all the one
number one contenders similar to like
kind of how khabib has done
jones too jonjo was nobody left for him
really he was fighting guys two and
three times
exactly but but you look at all the guys
that jones fought and if jones if we
take jones out of the picture and he
retired tomorrow like khabib did
you immediately start looking at dominic
reyes and john levojovic and
the guy with the thor hammer on his
chest he fights this weekend
uh santos thiago santos you know
um just a ton of big name guys you know
so it's
big name guys but they looked not that
great against a guy like jon jones you
know so
alexander gustafson if yeah i love him
exactly so
but man look at the light look at the
lightweight division connor
is the anchor he's like the biggest name
obviously you got me the new guy who
came in
who came in right at the right time tony
ferguson was a household name poor yeah
he was a household name justin gaichi
who
is a household name and i mean you've
gotten thrown in i mean you
suddenly like does it feel a lot
different being michael chandler
two months ago who was uh in
just you know in the not the xfl because
it's certainly a lot bigger than that
that's a shitty comparison but
it's it's similar i mean it's not it's
not the nfl you know
right yeah being adjacent right being
ufc adjacent to suddenly i mean this is
you know it's it's i mean it's
definitely like
it's like put you in a star spot in a
way you know it is it's cool and
and it and a lot of it or some of it had
to do with the way that i came over and
and the
i guess even i i did bruce buffer's
podcast and he's like he's
like michael yeah exactly it's time
podcast bruce buffer was like hey you
know i've been with the ufc now for 25
years and i'm hard-pressed to
rack in my brain trying to think of
another free agent that came over and
got this much splash
and this much you know momentum and part
of that is great but part of that also
you know uh kind of exposes you to some
hate too because people like who's this
guy think he is man why is the ufc
why are they force-feeding us mike this
michael chandler again who's this pretty
boy
yeah zach well that's part of it too
they're like this guy doesn't look like
he's just handsome
who's this lifeguard i read one comment
who's this lifeguard
exactly that's i'm like hey man i know
but it's like you even know cpr honestly
no i don't
unbelievable exactly man i can't even
swim
no it's like you know
but the good thing is i will get into
the octagon soon and people will realize
okay he's not just about
the bodyguard lifeguard looking dude
whatever and bodybuilder
someone called me a fitness model
because i you know the ufc took some
photos of me on the beach and i'm like
what am i supposed to do man i'm out
here on fight island i'm probably not
gonna fight
let me do something you know like yeah
uh so it's one of them deals where
you know just do a little bit of
research look up my fights on youtube
yeah i've lost but i've also won i've
won in dominant fashion
you'll see you'll see the passion that i
bring to the cage and being bring to
that
and i will bring to the octagon so it's
uh
because it feels much bigger a lot of
people this is their first introduction
to your name
exactly so it does and it does feel much
bigger it does you know the
the numbers are growing the the
notoriety is growing and in a lot of
ways
it it inspires me and motivates me to to
be better to
to work even harder to build even more
you know because like i said
it wasn't enough for me to just put on
the ufc gloves and put on the ufc fight
kit and take the photos
in front of the ufc green screen and get
on the ufc broadcast like man
i want to get inside that octagon and i
want to fight and i want to prove to not
prove i want to show the people who i am
win lose or draw that's that's going to
take care of itself
yeah but the passion that i bring to the
k to the octagon
the preparation and the manner at which
i prepare myself
is is all going to stay the same if if
not be even more increased right now and
i'm excited for the opportunity how big
is that white chair there now
and uh in um abu dhabi
the white chair at the yeah that big
white chair at the ufc thing and then
like a big white chair out there that
people were sitting in
in the w at the um at the hotel in abu
dhabi yeah at the ufc ring at the ring
out there didn't they have
a i didn't see a white chair he didn't
uh i just seen pictures of people
sitting in one
um did you see the picture was it like a
a wooden white chair or a beach
on the beach yeah it looks real big it
is big it is
it is it's really big and it's really
deep because i was like trying to lean
back and i couldn't
i got short legs don't tell anybody i
got some shorts
i mean i've watched a lot of hours of
footage of you i got some freaking short
legs
you can tell they're not extremely long
but yeah me and my i mean we have we
have a big couch in my house too and i
was like gosh dang i hate these long
couches man because
if i get my my low back up against the
back of the couch my little feet
dangling
off you know like you're waiting for
christmas morning
like i'm so excited mom and dad you know
um is there a fighter you think that
that would that doesn't want to fight
you in that in that top group
i will say for a lot of guys it's risky
because you're that new element it's
like
and you're coming from a different place
where i mean i'm sure all the guys are
familiar with you for sure
but it's not what they've been looking
at it's not their you know when they're
looking at their top ten it's not what
they've been looking at
the problem with mixed martial arts is
not the problem it's just the nature of
mixed martial arts is
everybody's tough to some degree then
there's some really then there's some
really really tough guys
who don't have that big of names and
then there's some really really big
names who aren't that tough
so there's this kind of paradigm shift
between
the two polar opposites of you know like
a guy like conor mcgregor his
i would say his name is bigger than his
fight skills but his fight skills are
way up there but his name is way bigger
just because he's such a big superstar
right but then he got a guy like myself
who
my fight skills much much supersede
my my my name status in the game
because i've been outside the ufc for so
long and that's not
me comparing my skill against conor i
think we match up well together whatever
but
connor or uh you know poirier and
ferguson were both offered
me offered to fight me october 24th they
both turned it down for their different
reasons and you know
some you know some they both brought up
money or they both brought up
don't whether it's timeline or maybe
they wanted to fight each other they
talked about you know
standing up for each other and then and
then poirier got the counter fight
or whatever so it was all an interesting
thing but i think i'm a dark horse of
the division
because people don't really want to
fight me because there's not really not
a lot of
upside to fighting me you know you could
fight it you can fight another guy in
the top 10 who's in the ufc who is a
household name like
i say a charizard charles oliveira he's
on a long flight
street yeah he's good he's got some wins
he's been in the ufc would you fight him
i would fight anybody right but when i
already have the opportunity to fight a
top five guy and i've been told i was
going to get a top five
guy right away poor yeah or ferguson
like why would i ever
think about and that was the problem too
right the
khabib's training partner freaking
everybody wanted me to fight him because
his
because his opponent rafael dossanos got
covered and fell off the card so
everybody was like oh yeah
i'm like why am i gonna fight number 12
right when i already basically have
a name on a contract that's in the top
five i'm gonna get a top five guy right
away i'm sorry if that makes people
feel a certain way i'm sorry if the fans
think that i'm entitled
or i'm sorry if the fans think that i
you know don't deserve it
maybe i do maybe i don't it's the ufc's
decision let me step into the cage let
me freaking
figure it out butt whipped or let me
prove to you guys that i deserve to be
in top five either way we'll know pretty
soon
man a lot of you just gotta wait to get
in there every time huh yeah
man well that's a problem that's the
problem with mixed martial arts man is
wrestling was great because if i lost it
was 48 hours 72 hours four three four
days until i got to get back in the win
column and get a win if i wanted you
know if i if i had the opportunity
mixed martial arts man if i lose it
takes me four five six months to get a
win
and that's why that time between fights
and that's why i
i went into a hole man i lost i lost
three fights in a row
688 days without a win back when i first
i've lost my first fight ever to eddie
alvarez very close
razor thin split decision lost my next
two fights because i just wasn't
prepared
mentally to lose a and then when i did
lose it took me so long
to get in to get to my next competition
that i self-sabotaged or
or didn't build myself up enough and
told myself the lies that i wasn't as
good as i thought i was and
my doubters were correct and all that
kind of stuff um
it's not my journey to come back from
because especially when that's your
first fight
the first fight that first fight that i
lost and there was just like man
i can't can't i'm not who i thought i
was they were they were right
the naysayers were right the media who
didn't believe in me was right
you know and then i just lost through
and that you know someday when i write a
book it'll be called 688 days
talking about you know and eddie alvarez
is a gangster
is there a guy god he's such a dude when
you're watching he remind he reminds me
like the greatest
guy to like i don't know what he reminds
me of
is there a guy out there when you're
fighting them when they who's the
craziest look in the eye person you've
ever seen
and it doesn't have nothing to do with
their fighting skills or anything but
who've you ever gotten in the ring with
and you're like
jesus christ this guy is missing a
little bit of something
uh for me uh i think there's this guy
named dave rickles
who uh i fought twice who's uh
he he had a he has a really pretty good
career he actually went over to bare
knuckle
bare knuckle fighting so that'll show
you wow he's you know you got to have
kind of have a screw loose to go to that
place and fight freaking bare knuckle
right yeah yeah um but man he was just
he had this look in his eyes he was a
little nuts he was a little crazy
he was he's the kind of guy who would
carry like he was caveman it was
his uh his name so he'd wear a barney
rubble flintstones
thing to the kids and carry a big old
club like barney flips
flintstone one time they they wheeled
him out in a coffin he opened himself up
pulled himself out of the coffin and got
out there like
he was a true showman but he was also
kind of a little bit nuts you know um
he was he was probably one of the
craziest guys i've ever fought
is there more are you noticing over the
time more of that wrestling kind of
flair
get into uh fighting as well or has it
gotten
less as your career has gotten into
bigger fights
and you know more higher purse fights
and stuff and you
you know just more professional is there
more of that at a lower level or do you
think there's just more that coming into
the sport everywhere
i think i think there was a i think
there was the conor mcgregor
conor mcgregor era um that said okay
i need a trash talk i need gucci
sunglasses i need gucci flip-flops
i need a uh real or fake
good-looking watch i don't care if it's
fake i just want people to think i got
money
i got to talk i got to wear wear certain
things i think connor came in
and it worked for connor conor mcgregor
is
an anomaly he is great on the mic he is
well read he's well
well rehearsed you're crazy if you don't
think that a lot of the stuff connor has
said on the on this microphone
wasn't rehearsed in the back in you know
in in in his room before he's going to
bed at night he's just rehearsing
different things
and so i think when i first got into the
sport there was almost none of it
then conor came in i think a lot of
people started you know
trying to look high class nice cars and
this that and the other thing which
that's also just instagram models
there's so many of them out there so
we're also in the age of instagram
instagram but i also think
the tide is now shifting towards the
respectful honorable warriors i mean
look at our division i mean like poirier
is one of the most respectable guys
ever conor punched a guy punched an old
man in an irish whiskey bar and then
like his next fight was like he
apologized and he
he had his hair slicked back beat up
cowboy cerrone but it was a nice he he's
trying to
play the respectable card realizing like
man i don't want to keep carrying around
this heaviness it's
it's a lot of heaviness to have a lot of
animosity in your life you know man like
you you can have certain spats with
people like if you're not on good terms
with people man like you don't need
enemies in life yeah it sucks
just so for anybody who's listening
right now if you've got toxic people in
your life
now imagine taking that and having a
toxic relationship between you and the
guy that you're fighting
how how would you perform when you have
that some people do well with it some
people do really bad with it i
personally do really bad with it
bellator tried to build up this big
animosity thing between me and pitbull
and i'm not saying i lost because of it
but i didn't feel myself going into that
fight
so to answer your question i think the
sport is moving towards the more
respectable and i'll tell you right now
had a conversation with dana white on
fight island he told me hey kid
keep doing exactly what you're doing
we're getting a ton of great feedback
from the ufc staff from the ufc fans
from all the social media pages from all
the content all the stuff like people
are you are resonating with the fan base
with the audience and
i'm the kind of guy where i'm just going
to be respectful i'm i'm gonna hey i
have honor in the sport
integrity of my life high character high
reputation and
it's always worked out well for me
pretty you know could i have sold some
more tickets and made some more money by
you know custom spitting fighting a
little bit more
maybe but i wouldn't have felt better it
wouldn't be not doing it yeah exactly
exactly maybe not let's get this
question right here man we might be
about to finish up what do we have here
riley
what's up theo what's up michael this is
quincy coming at you from the great
state of texas
my question for michael chandler being
uh just lay out for me
what your dream career in the ufc is
when a lot of guys get here
they think you know hey i want the money
fights you know and do the connor gig
or you know i just want to chase glory i
just want a legacy i want a name
you know i want to know what that
championship so just lay out what's your
ideal career with the ufc and where do
you see it going
gang gang bro yeah cause that belt's
back in play now man it is that's a good
question man because that's
it's good because it's it's like what's
what's the philosophy of of why i'd made
the decision you know just just to give
a little context i left
i left the relative uh the relative
surety of
easier fights and good money in bellator
good contract and bellator
comfortability of
being the big fish little pond and being
kind of the poster boy for an
organization
to essentially come over to ufc ask to
get thrown to the sharks thrown to the
wolves right away and see what happens
so to answer that question i think a guy
like
gaichi or tony ferguson
fighting and showing the fans who i am
win that fight fight the way exactly the
way that i fight
prove to the fans okay this guy's here
to stay this guy's a legit contender for
the lightweight belt
and then fight for the belt whether it's
habib or whether it's connor poirier
whether it's
whether i'm the number one contender
after beating one of those guys and then
connor poirier is the number one
contender
we fight for the title sometime middle
of 2021 and then
uh and then after that just defend the
belt and get the big fights because i
think
and a crown they should put a crown on
you guys man crown would be cool you
know or like a metal you know like
like an olympic gold medal you know yeah
crown would be crown would be cool
but keep going sorry oh no but then
you'll get a crown hopefully
and then uh and then defend the belt a
few times defend the belt a few times
and then for me i don't say get the big
fights just for the money but you get
the big fights because that's how you
get the attention you know it's like
it's like the gary vee uh approach of
capturing as much attention as possible
if you don't have people's attention or
you can't get people's attention they
can't
they won't pay attention to you and they
won't you know
life is all about who knows you who
trusts you
and then who's going to to buy what
you're selling not just
money-wise not just buying products but
by what you're selling like
what kind of motivation are you selling
people what kind of
character are you selling people what
kind of what kind of theos are you are
you selling to the people so that you
can reach the masses and for me it's all
about
touching as many people as i possibly
can through this platform that i've been
given
touching every walk of life every corner
of the globe hopefully
and uh so winning the world title
and then getting big fights either
defending the belt or you know
bmf belt or the big you know the big
fights with the big name guys to get as
much
attention and eyeballs on me not for the
you know not for the ego of it but for
the platform of it
yeah that platform yeah that's a good
point you know once people know you then
you can do stuff with it
yeah i mean that's and that's really
what it is because it's it's a catch-22
and it's like
he just did that for attention and it's
like yeah as long as you don't ever
sacrifice your morals or your character
it's okay to do things for attention
you know like i came over the ufc
essentially for attention you know i
came over to ufc for
competition competition and attention
those are two things that i get from the
ufc that i'm that i couldn't
not that i wasn't getting a bellator but
i get more in the ufc
so it's okay to want more attention
especially if you've done things to earn
it you know
was there a time previously you were
going to come to the ufc and it didn't
work out or was there
how long did this i mean how long is
this whole convo going on is it one of
those ongoing conversations for like a
decade what is it like so it's one of
those it's one of those deals where i
never actually became a free agent there
was some reports out there that
chandler's a free agent he's you know
he's gonna you know but i ever actually
you know two years ago and four years
ago
was on the last fight on my contract
ended up re-signing with bellator with
the one
fight left on my contract so i was never
a free agent until
august of of 2020 and uh
it just seemed like the right time this
time back then
because it's also it also depended on
what the ufc lightweight division looked
like too
you know two years ago the landscape
looked a lot different you had habib as
the champion
you had conor off doing 100 million
dollar fights with floyd mayweather
he could come back leapfrog me whenever
you had poorier
coming in you one or one of those guys
had an interim title two years ago it
was either tony or
it wasn't poor yeah because i think
point was after that but maybe it was
tony i think tony had an interim title
habib had the title habib wasn't coming
back necessarily so it was just a weird
time
it was a weird time for me to come in
now it
exactly what we thought now it's perfect
two years later i'm coming in at this
time which couldn't have been even more
so
two years ago and i said this to dana
when i spoke to him i said listen two
years ago
four years ago i wouldn't have been the
guy that you needed to be to come in and
be the champion and be the superstar of
this division and i truly believe that
i'm going to be that i don't say that in
a
cocky i don't say that in a cocky way i
just believe like i want
you got to believe it i just believe
that that's that's what's going to
happen and
and maybe there's going to be people
that laugh at me i fall flat on my face
and that's fine but at least i find out
you know that's how i feel in my heart
right now and you can't you can't
knock a man for how he feels in his
heart you know a man who hitches his
dream to a star
that's the only way you can go out and
create create impact in your life and do
amazing things so
that's what i'm doing and man it's been
uh it's been cool but i never became a
free agent until just this year
and it just never seemed like the right
time to become a free agent until this
year
damn so it worked out perfect well i'm
inspired how do you feel riley
i loved every minute of it come on riley
i like that man yeah
you're great thanks man did it make you
feel better about the girl
yeah hey there are so many fish in the
sea man
i didn't even meet my wife till i was
like 27 years old
yeah where'd you meet her at dude that's
a funny story
crazy story actually this tooth right
here
chipped it like broke it in half in in
college
my buddy justin cole jumped off the side
of the pool jumped on me
and i bit it down broke it but i told
them that i did it in wrestling so they
sent me to this mizzou
a casual move there
yeah come on dude this sent it to them
to send me to the mizzou dentist the guy
who did all the dentist stuff
his name was kent willett i knew who he
was because he was a bible study leader
of my bible study leader he had a great
great uh reputation in town and i was
looking at these pictures of him i'm
like man
who's this cute little brunette girl and
all these family pictures of him it must
be his daughter and he's awesome i like
him
and i don't even know him if she's half
as good as she must be by being his
daughter he must you know she must be
awesome he fixes my tooth i don't say
anything but i start looking her up on
facebook and just freaking fall in love
with her
yeah i've been there before yeah right
and then a couple a couple
weeks later i joined a bible study and
they start talking about this brie will
it girl and
that was her name pre will it i'm like
man that's that's that freaking girl man
like i love that girl and now
i hear them talking i'm just like kind
of listening like oh so she goes to
school here like what
is she cool what path does she take to
walk exactly yeah no well she wasn't in
the town she was she was out of town
you know she was a couple hours away in
indiana but luckily through facebook i
think i frame requested her
she said yes because i had i had some
friends
that she respected and were like well if
he's friends with these guys he must be
all right
ends up being five years later until i
finally freaking send her a facebook
message i'm like hey
how are things like acted i kind of
acted like i knew her and she
you know she uh she you know responded
we talked
for a couple months she said hey i'm i'm
doing residencies or i'm applying for
residencies i'm getting off here here's
my email so we emailed back and forth
for almost two years
she would she would wait like four five
six months to respond to me
i would email her and she wait freaking
three months to respond to me and i'd
email her right away
she'd wait two months to respond to me
60 days for two years you know and then
finally i wore her down enough she got
coffee with me and then we fell in love
right there january 24th 2013 and called
his coffee in columbia missouri and
you met her the other night yeah
beautiful lady man we had a nice time i
came over for the um
just to watch some of the election and
yeah it was a nice time man yeah it was
fun man and then uh took some
to go played i wish i would have taken a
bigger one yeah dude you should have man
we still got like
six pounds of brisket and i was thinking
i was like somebody's like i'm gonna
take it to go plate i'm like yes
they only got three people living here
yeah yeah yeah you need all of this
four-year-old exactly i was going out of
town yeah dude i'm glad you took some
that was still awesome if you want
something that was fun man um
yeah that's like my that must yeah my
whole thing is like oh yeah i'll send
girls like dms i'd be like hey did i see
you at the grocery
and then they're like i live in moscow
and i'm like oh
well yeah i was there yeah
but i've seen those i must have been on
my friend's face time
he was walking through the grocery i saw
you but in the background
his name was vladimir yeah yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] great right over here um
that's all i got riley any questions you
want me to ask for you
all right michael chandler man dude it's
it's a pleasure to watch your ride man
and thank you so much for coming and
joining us today man
man thanks for having me it's fun yeah
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel like these
[Music]
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it in my
it's gonna take a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself online
that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]